welcome to Pumped up primary America in
case you haven't noticed yet
presidential candidates are flexing some
serious muscle to win over your vote and
send Joe Biden's Beach bot into
retirement one Outlet sums it up this
way quote 2024 presidential contest is
careened into a kind of testosterone
primary a frenetic fit Boy Summer side
quest in which candidates are drawing
fewer contrasts on policy improving more
keen on comparing Feats of Strength
Miami mayor Francis Suarez is bragging
about placing sixth in a 5K run in Cedar
Rapids Iowa
Senator Tim Scott tossing around the
pigskin with his campaign manager
Ron DeSantis baseball cards are getting
passed around highlighting his stint in
the Little League World Series
and who can forget those shirtless RFK
Junior workouts the beefy Democrat just
revealing a secret to getting buff
I'm on an anti-aging protocol from my
doctor that includes uh uh
um testosterone replacement
and uh but I don't take any steroids I
don't take any anabolic steroids or
anything like that
Greg you were right when you said he was
on something oh it's obvious but when
you can't be that cut it's 70. you know
I mean look at Harold
but I mean think about it what a low bar
right it's and you know why it's you
know why Dana it's because people in DC
just aren't in good shape at all if you
you look at the White House briefing
room it looks like the Star Wars bar
just hideous hideous people right am I
every single one of them except for Fox
but you know I'm happy to see you know
I'm happy I think we need some muscle
heads in the white house we need to
crush that cement ceiling because we
need to put a squat rack in the Oval
Office and pilates in the Lincoln
bedroom
all right so it was uh sixth place in a
5K in Cedar Rapids good yeah I actually
going to mention that I just there were
16 people in the race I mean look but I
could I don't like to run I like to walk
I could have walked uh might might have
been able to do that in Iowa I think
here's a couple of things when Biden is
on the beach yeah and you can see him
there right and he goes to the beach a
lot right as Mark Halperin says in his
newsletter uh when you see a turtle on a
fence post you know it didn't get there
itself so the White House is probably
thinking okay we've got to figure out a
way to get some pictures out there of
you know President Biden I don't know if
that's how they thought it would turn
out right it was to share around but
um that's that and then you have I think
that people that are voters are inspired
by people because a lot of people want
to be healthy so they're like okay well
that's not a bad thing to Aspire to
however the thing that will matter the
most is what are we going to do about
the economy and get this country moving
again you're going to lower my taxes are
you going to do something like that not
just this does this appeal to female
voters when they see guys competing
throwing the football getting out there
yeah
here's the thing look when people are
competitive I mean physically whether
they run or play tennis or whatever it
is I mean you like to see energy
discipline perseverance they're
competing with themselves you know it
it's to me it's a sign of someone who is
functioning at their best capacity and I
love to see it look we have been so
inundated with Joe Biden you know
falling down slipping uh falling off a
bicycle I mean this is what we want we
want someone who has the energy and the
discipline and recognizes that you know
in order for you to feel for me to clear
my head I used to run all the time I
mean it's part of what we do to be on
top of our game used to run after people
very good so you were in Congress when
in the 90s late 90s earlier so Clinton
was wearing those little short shorts he
was jogging out there I mean this has
been going around for a while
there's no doubt when I was in Congress
John thune who's the senator from South
Dakota we uh Kilmeade wrote about this
we uh we won the Congressional
basketball tournament and I'll admit it
was not stiff competition but it was a
bipartisan thing and so working out and
all of it is great but we shouldn't de
elephant in the room is you have two
candidates on the on Front Runners who
are close to 80 years old uh and we
questioned the mental we question the
Physical Agility and Acuity so these
issues are are there now the physical
fitness thing if we're going to do that
I'd rather just have Patrick Mahomes and
Travis Kelsey be president vice
president if that's what we're looking
for but I think voters eventually I mean
I understand what they're doing but I
hope they don't get too far away from
talking about how we keep workers and
entrepreneurs and our national security
prepared for the challenges and
opportunities uh I just as a 70 year old
to table I'd like to finish them Chris
Christie
terrible
okay are there any shirtless pictures of
you when you were running oh no I'd have
it on my wall
I have the covice news we cover that's
true there was no there was no spread no
centerfold in the Newsweek there were
nothing okay now that I know all right
and while the candidates beef up MSNBC
things working out something only
racists do the liberal Network getting
mocked after tweeting out this op-ed
that talks about the far rights
obsession with Fitness it claims that a
network of online fascist Fitness chat
groups on the encrypted platform
telegram are recruiting and radicalizing
young men with Neo-Nazi and white
supremacist extremist ideologies
Joe Rogan among those mocking this quote
being healthy is far right holy blank
uh Greg
um your thoughts it's it's all part of
this weird thing that anything that you
measure is somehow reflective of like
white supremacy whether it's math you
measure science weight achievement uh
work output anytime you have to like put
a number on something that's inherently
racist and so if you find satisfaction
in increasing resistance through weights
and building muscle then that's also an
adherence to some kind of zealotry and
and then if you see a black bodybuilder
all you will say is well that's how
seductive white supremacy is that even
black people are working out but you
know what's interesting if you go down
the line of what the whoa this makes so
much sense
the woke say Fitness is racist they say
obesity is body positive they reject
math and grammar as bigotry they uh they
say debate is physically uh dangerous so
you have to cancel debate and ultimately
beauty is is uh uh patriarchal right
there it's a socialized concept created
by men so if you're woke all that's left
for you is to be out of shape
fat sloppy have terrible social and
career skills and when you look at their
mug shots on antifa they nail it I mean
that's why they look so miserable they
reject all truth and beauty and all
Aesthetics and all measurements yeah
antifa could spend more time on the
squat rack Dana you would think so that
would be quite the bushes yes exactly
that's what they do you bet they do
um and that's disgusting that they do
that suppose I gonna say oh the other
thing in the op-ed she says is that
working out from home that this is now
that this is the thing okay well we got
pelotons right before the pandemic
Remember Have you ever heard one
conservative thing said on Peloton ever
never okay this is everybody working out
from home this is not a conservative
movement that's how I keep the movement
that's how I keep up with the months
because every month is different on
politics for the month you just have to
like let it pass you by
Janine you're very fit does that make
you a white supremacist I'm the last
white supremacist I mean the the whole
idea is backwards I don't know why they
why they have to insist that if they're
not in a particular place then and if
you are then you need to be hated and
they don't know how else to do it other
than to claim you're a racist or you're
a xenophobe I'm not I'm surprised
they're not saying that if you're fit
you're a xenophobe too you're a racist
you're everything that's anti-left it's
too easy it's too dumb I mean Greg is
right it's just everything is piled into
well you look good so that's disgusting
okay and your world maybe being healthy
is a good thing I stay I play soccer
with my eight-year-old and he wears me
out in 20 30 minutes I can't keep up
with them so you guys play sports at all
Chris Christie I love you I mean don't
let him don't let him sit about me the
the
this is we talk about people inject race
too much I mean everything can't be
about race uh and being healthy eating
well means that you will live a fuller
life uh you will live longer which means
you'll have an opportunity to be a
Democrat for a longer time no you'll
have a chance to be a republican for
whatever it is you want to be this is a
good thing so please let's Tamp it down
Harold Ford Jr the black face of white
workouts oh my God
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now